these are some fans I'll say good I'll
take it but I'll find him I got a friend
me and him get on playing show me your
door and beat the [__] out of it
we don't take criticism well
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big in the 70s
it was played by Lou Ferrigno ladies
[__] is so big
once Liam got sentenced to community
service and he worked off his hours at a
public swimming pool as a diving board
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
he has to beg tourists to discourage
them from dropping pennies off the top
of it to the people below that has been
Hollywood babble-on for this week later
this edition here in Sin City Las Vegas
USA I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
apple [__] on everybody good night
[Applause]
[Music]
you